let's talk about the fighting in
ethiopia
the government's launched a military
offensive in the north
in a region called tagrai the conflict
could turn into a civil war
thousands of refugees have crossed into
sudan the death toll
is bound to rise at the center of it all
is ethiopia's prime minister
a nobel peace prize winner war is
epitome of fail
for all involved he would know abby used
to be a soldier who now has
another fight on his hands
so how did the fighting start and what
is this conflict really about
ethiopia is a huge country with many
ethnic groups and political parties
governing them has at times been
difficult for the central government in
addis ababa
there have been a few years of economic
growth and relative calm
now though things are starting to heat
up here's why
ethiopia is divided into 10 regions they
loosely represent different ethnic
groups
each one has some autonomy but the
center of power is an ethiopia's capital
to gray where most of the fighting has
been happening is in the north
the government there is called the tplf
and it even has its own regional army
they have a large number of militias and
special forces that have been trained in
hundreds of thousands the tplf
wasn't just in charge of the tigray
region it pretty much ran the country
for nearly 30 years
even though the tegrans are minority
just six percent of the population
the tblf was the head of a coalition of
regional parties
but many people saw it as autocratic and
dysfunctional
they locked up hundreds of journalists
and political dissidents
and massive protests eventually brought
them down the chaos allowed abiamed
a young leader seen as a visionary to
get elected
he's from the oromo ethiopia's largest
ethnic group
political prisoners were freed
opposition parties were allowed to
operate he promised a new era of
democratic reforms
and an end to years of autocracy abby
even won a nobel prize
for making peace with eritrea next door
for as long as the tplf was in power
ethiopia was involved in a border
standoff with eritrea
so they didn't appreciate abi's new
friendship with the eritrean president
the tiguays have got a long history of
animosity
with not just isaiah saw working the
president of eritrea but eritrea
as a whole so here's prime minister abe
with the nobel prize and all these
ambitious ideas about how to keep the
peace in ethiopia
and modernize the economy part of his
plan was to disband the old governing
coalition
and unify the country under a new
prosperity party
but some including the tplf saw that as
taking power from the regions
they also saw it as a power grab by abi
the tplf pulled out completely
and they're accused of doing all kinds
of things to sabotage abby's success
they saw him as undermining the
coalition
um sidelining it also moving very hard
against the tplf itself abi ahmed
removed members of the tblf from top
positions
many were arrested and prosecuted for
corruption and abuse of power
so abi ahmed who at 44 as africa's
youngest leader
made a lot of enemies really quick two
years ago someone
even tried to assassinate him ethiopia
has become
proud
[Music]
so that brings us to what's happening
now back in march abi's government
postponed elections because of the
pandemic
but in september the tplf held one
anyway
that escalated things the parliament
called the vote illegal the tplf said it
didn't recognize obvi as a legitimate
leader
and tblf forces attacked a government
military base
so abe sent in troops and it all blew up
from there
now this is where we'd show you footage
of the war but we just don't have much
the government has cut to dry off the
roads the airport and the internet
so here's what we're hearing we know the
government is launching airstrikes
the tblf has launched rocket attacks of
its own even across degrees borders
soldiers on both sides are being killed
civilians too
we're just not sure how many it's
realistic to be talking about hundreds
of fatalities
already but it is not clear
thousands of people have been forced to
leave their homes many are crossing into
sudan
[Music]
imagine
and we're already hearing reports of
terrible violence
though we can't independently verify
them amnesty international is
investigating potential war crimes
including hundreds of people reportedly
hacked to death
the other worry is that this war could
spread and drag in other countries
and it's kind of already happening the
tplf says its old enemy eritrea has sent
troops to help ethiopian government
forces which eritrea denies
whatever's happening the point is the
tplf sees eritrea and abi ahmed as being
on the same side
which could explain why the tplf has now
turned on its neighbor
at least three rockets have been fired
from ethiopia
into eritrea potentially widening the
conflict
so what do ethiopians think of what's
going on
some support the offensive on tagray
these people for instance are donating
blood for wounded soldiers
abi's supporters feel he had no choice
but to act
because they say the tblf undermined him
at every turn
and stirred up ethnic violence but other
ethiopians
say the prime minister isn't living up
to his promises and that instead of
pursuing peace he's chosen
foreign
in a lot of ways this is a battle
between the old guard
and the new the tplf started this fight
but now it's about
how it's going to end whatever abe did
to earn his nobel peace prize
he'll be feeling the pressure to do it
again
this story is moving fast and there's a
lot happening in ethiopia not just in
tegra
we have a lot of reporters in the region
covering the story
so make sure to visit aljazeera.com to
get the very latest
we'll see you next week